oh all right guys let's uh a little TV
some big announcements coming from DC's
mayor and the DC Health Department
within just the last hour a state of
emergency declared and recommending that
large gatherings including conferences
and conventions be postponed or canceled
a bankstown mother and daughter have
been charged after a fight over toilet
paper in Woolworths yes zombie attack in
Alexandria let's look at the five-day
forecast and we'll see the temperatures
are still fluctuating but the chances of
death have stabilized at about 99.99% oh
mama I'm worried about Nathan that boy
licks
everything he's been licking the slide
at the chick-fil-a play plays he's been
licking the floors in the public
bathroom yeah that was Nate oh he likes
to lick the toilets he likes to lick his
brothers he likes to lick dogs if
anyone's going to get this virus it's
going to be Nathan hey Nathan you
feeling okay there buddy
guys I think Nathan's infected right
[Music]
maintain social distancing
[Music]
did the nerve guys you ready Tommy yeah
you ready mama get ready guys here he
comes
oh no he's armed
he was in the sector
[Music]
[Applause]
we get the wings is it too late
oh no Jacob has it affected too and he's
gonna come and get us
run
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
oK we've got to deal with this situation
we've got Nathan trapped in the basement
there's no time for dabbing zombies are
taking over our family pandemic is over
the world
Oh dabbing over baby you stay up here
are we go downstairs a deal with our
child mommy Tommy move the barricade
alright he's down here somewhere so dark
all right Nathan I know you're doing
here I'm not gonna hurt you I'm just
gonna hand sanitizer Laurie but we gotta
get out of here we gotta leave the
children all they ever do is pick their
nose and lick things will be better off
this way we'll be safe don't worry
[Applause]
all right I gotta make a last stand
I'm not getting sick stay back unless
you've washed your hands and often to
your elbow come over here I'll walk off
on your food that I am vocal I wanna
tell you and it's delicious this is the
first time I've been healthy in like
three months
you always get me sick you'll get any
stomach flu you can't even call you get
me strong
wait are you coughing on your darts your
monsters
[Music]
oh no another bullet
make sure there's one bullet left in my
cell
[Applause]
[Applause]
well guys I hope you enjoyed this video
if you want to see more nerf war skits
from the outdoor boys YouTube channel
don't forget to click Subscribe and
check the video description for links to
our other videos stay safe out there and
wash your hands and we'll see you next
Saturday if you like this video don't
forget to check out the outdoor boys
youtube channel where we have hundreds
of videos just like this and don't
forget to click subscribe so you can see
other great videos every Saturday
morning and hit that belt like you'll
get notifications thanks for watching
[Music]